how much money do we print the last 24
months what's the dollar amount no idea
over 5 trillion over 5 trillion more
than 40 percent of all the money in
history of america has been printed in
the last 24 months okay
now they take that money and they send
what do you call it all these money they
send to police china stimulus checks to
people
the people that are getting the money
with stimulus checks what do you think
they're doing with their money well for
one thing it brought a lot of kids out
of poverty no they didn't yes they did
what do you think then the statistics
would have gone up but what do you think
they do with that money what do you
think they do with that money you tell
me
will you you tell me what they do with
that money
if i'm accustomed to spending money and
i'm spending the money buying stuff
i buy more stuff
and when you buy more stuff who's
running those companies that sell more
stuff
the people at the top so the money
always flows to the top so essentially
the politicians that you want to
increase the taxes for
they're the reason why billionaires
increased their net worth 70 percent the
last two years well there's a couple
different things going on it's not a
blanket statement so
and this is what i want to get to the
heart about it because the facts support
that yes people have spent a lot more
money but they've also more people have
gotten out of debt this is what happens
when you print five trillion dollars
there's options people have saved a lot
more people have
um because with unemployment and
stimulus checks they've had a lot more
in their bank accounts they've they paid
off debt i think this is the first time
in
decades that
um debt basically personal debt
decreased
uh since the pandemic so it's not just a
blanket statement
i'm sorry i'm sorry adam you can't say
something like that no no you can't say
something like that
okay
so go to where you just went i'm just
saying that there's not everyone spent
all their money some people saved some
people got out of debt but this is what
happens
let's talk about that guys like you
realize if i give you if i have a
hundred dollars right now i give it to
you
did that hundred dollars disappear
no at the end of the day the money
flowed to the top but let me let me go a
little bit further if i give you a
hundred dollars
did that money disappear no
the money just transferred to who to you
if you
give that hundred dollars to him did the
money disappear no it just went to him
if the money goes from him to him did
that money disappear that hundred
dollars still out there right it's just
not in my hand not on your hand not in
his hand it's now in his hands right
okay fine
that five trillion dollars that we put
in the economy where does that five
trillion dollars go to
so oh my god i paid so many people's
credit card than in college debt really
where did that five trillion go to
pet patent but where did that fight i'm
asking it's gone everywhere it's gone
all of it circulated all over the
economy a lot of it a lot of it a lot of
it a lot of it went to the stock market
and that goes to basically where elon
musk it's bigger than that guys it's
bigger than that this guy is sitting
here just gave this a strategy on how to
ruin a nation who gives a [ __ ] where
that five trillion dollars went to
here's what a five trillion dollars a
hundred percent
to our debt yeah
that five trillion dollars is debt like
what's on one side of the bank do you
realize who's the speaker today our
guest today is john perkins economic
hitman where the business philosophy is
what we can kill him with the sword or
debt
and we're like oh but we paid off
college [ __ ] open we paid off credit oh
but we bought more bitcoin oh but we
bought more nfts oppa we no [ __ ] the
country you love
is officially enslaved
to others and what do we have to do with
this money they have to get that money
from somewhere so that we print some
more money oh let's help the poor even
more
this is not the strategy
i'd love nothing more this is a 99 cent
store guy i'm a guy my parents got a
divorce i didn't have any money when we
grew up i'm a guy that went to the
military was going to do military for 40
years if a guy didn't sit there and say
hey you need to kind of figure out how
money works where the hell am i today
i'm just another guy that's sitting
there saying can you please send us more
stimulus checks this is not the right
strategy
we want the same mission to help
middle-income
median income to go higher but the way
to do it isn't to send more money to
people that is not the strategy because
that keeps hurting
that keeps validating your business
model when you went and sat down with
people like you know the guatemala guy
jacopo guzman when you sat down with
ecuador aguilera jaime aguilera when you
went to sat down with panama omar torios
when he went and sat down with you know
venezuela when you all this stuff it
just validates the formula works also
what are you saying that it's good to
have a country where three individuals
have as much wealth as half the
population i'd call that an oligarchy
what would you call it i'd really like
to know what
do you say
is that a democracy do you like sports
some what do you what sport do you like
soccer soccer
hockey you like hockey who's your
favorite hockey player
i haven't been following this year
actually who's the greatest hockey
player of all time gretzky is it fair
that he scored more assists and goals
than anybody else by a mile
that's a shame
john
i'm appalled
that we allow somebody
to beat number two by so much with goals
and assists he should never
beat the greatest hockey player prior to
him by so much that is embarrassing we
should limit how much he should have
beat second place because
we should give more minutes to the other
guy because god forbid wayne gretzky why
are you getting so many minutes we
shouldn't let him play so much we
shouldn't have these success stories
let's keep people less let's only beat
the record by one goal not not not 600
gold so you're saying you're saying that
the american economy is a sports game
yes it is
you're playing again capitalism is a
game so socialism the difference is
capitalism and the difference is
capitalism you control the game
based on what you said do you think you
think what the united states has today
is capitalism
with a touch of social uh with a touch
of social programs
what we have is predatory capitalism or
oligarchic capitalism there's a there's
not true capitalism there is because
true capitalism yeah true capitalism
you know the definition of capitalism is
that the means of production
manufacturing and commerce are not owned
by the government they're owned by
individuals you're going to lose this
argument when you go keep going yeah
we'll see about that i should go for it
i'm enjoying this go ahead
i have to another that i think i'd have
an argument like this with an iranian i
mean anyway this is why i invite you
back because i enjoy our conversation so
let me continue so so in in our form of
capitalism yeah uh the india they got
the government does not own individual
enterprises okay but the individual
enterprise owners own the government so
when you go and you talk about our
politicians and what they're what
they're doing and so forth that's
because they're owned by the oligarchy
that's because they're owned by the
billionaires what's the problem
so who's the problem the system is the
problem
that
the fact the fact that corporations and
the corporation owners can put so much
money
into this is what they call the crony
council guess what so guess what they
call oligarchy so guess what so guess
what so then so then this goes to one
thing so you think we should have
lobbyists
not on the lobbyists
right now we have 300 lobbyists to every
member of congress you think that's a
good thing no you think we should have
lobbyists period
i think
i think you can have middlemen but
there's not not lobbyists that are that
are so totally selfish how are people do
you see senators and congressmen
retirement become lobbyists making six
million a year a lot okay so what do you
think happens there why do we have that
that's part of the bribery that's part
of the corruption
we shouldn't have that i agree okay then
so we have one area that we agree with
we agree that the reason why these
billionaires can get away with that is
because they have lobbyists that they're
paying money and these senators and
congressmen if you got a half a million
dollars to stay quiet in 1980 what the
hell do you think they're getting behind
closed doors
okay if you got a half a million dollars
today quite a 1980 what do you think
these senators and congressmen are
getting wallets and here's 800 000
do me a favor can you make sure you hurt
the other small business owner so i can
whoop his ass i've actually heard that
that if congressman can be bought for
ten thousand dollars can you come out it
was a hundred thousand can come on
you're cheaper today come on your side
but if you really want to push for you
then it's 100 000. i've heard that's the
100 000 number but i don't think that's
a good system though i don't either okay
so we're on the same page with that but
it's not the fault of for example if i
so so it's the fault of whoever created
those laws
not the fault of the capitalist if you
allow players to use steroids if you
allow players to use steroids and it's
legal guess what that's the law
if you don't it's not the law you know
the mlb is no longer testing for
steroids what just happened with the
russian skater
she's not allowed to use steroids but
she did and she's and and and she's been
forgiven for it i just i think so i
guess they're still struggling with that
so we tell me how many people are
watching the olympics today we've been
you're telling me are you are you
watching it i think i'm in it
the only person i know that's watching
it is my dad and he's watching this
curling i'm like dad what the hell are
you watching and they're watching this
curling game that's going on but but the
point but the point i'm trying to make
to you is it ain't the capitalist it's
the lawmaker
well but the capitalists own the
lawmaker no because they are for sale
if they weren't for sale this wouldn't
be the case why are they for sale who do
you blame so do you blame the prostitute
or the john
the prostitute has a choice not to be a
prostitute
john has a choice not to be john no but
wait a minute if the prostitute chooses
not to be a prostitute then john doesn't
can't find a process
and the prostitute goes broke because
she's got no other job no she'll find a
different way to make her money
that's not her maybe no no it's not
maybe that's not how life works no way
that's not how life works let me explain
to you how life works and you know this
is how life works
you tell a kid
listen
if you
don't figure out a way to pay rent you
got to kind of figure out what you're
going to do if you're going to live here
in rent for me you're 22 years old
you've got to kind of pay 600 bucks a
month no you don't get a job you're
you're out of luck you gotta go live
with your friends
you're a terrible dad fine you're right
i'm a terrible dad you're a terrible
renter you never pay rent what do i'm
going to do with you go figure life out
that kid leaves
he does some stuff that he wants to
retaliate against that smokes weed does
a little coke goes out there does
ecstasy does everything he can to trash
his dad he's gonna eventually get a job
and if he doesn't get a job and ruins
his life the father couldn't have done
anything about that in the first place
that's on the kid the kid has to
eventually figure out a way to survive
so that prostitute will figure out a way
to make money she doesn't have to go
that route
capitalism works it's the laws
that get people to do things that hurt
others because the laws allow that to
happen so let's look at a little bit of
american history i agree that capitalism
works sure but at the end of the
american revolution the continental
congress and what became the congress
were very concerned because the the
revolution was really about the east
india company that was more than the
crown but the crown was very dependent
on the east india company crown of
england and so
they passed a law that said
no no company no nobody could get a
corporate license a corporate charter
unless they could prove that they're
going to serve a public interest and
charters lasted for only 10 years
at the end of the 10 years you had to go
back and prove that to show demonstrate
that you had proof served a public
interest and then you could maybe get
another charter also in there was you
could no company could buy another
company or sell itself to another
company
those laws were there to protect us
against corporate power because the the
founders were very concerned about
corporate power because of the east
india company those laws continued for
100 years almost about 100 years until
john d rockefeller came along and he
wanted to drill for oil in new jersey in
delaware and he says you know i can't i
can't drill for oil i can't have a 10
years it takes a lot longer to drill for
oil i got to be able to buy out these
other companies they're competing with
me it's the only way we can get oil so
he went to the the legislature of new
jersey first and later delaware and he
said you know if you change the law so
that i can have unlimited powers yeah uh
i'll i'll give a lot of campaign money
to you legislation for that
yeah and and that has continued and it's
it's grown and grown and grown to the
point where corporations and their
owners have so much power over our
politicians now we can argue all you
want about who's who about the
prostitution and the john we can argue
about it but who is who's at fault is it
the politicians or is it the people that
are bribing the politicians basically
that are offering them these incredibly
lucrative positions when they leave or
even while they're there for campaign
financing and then when they leave if
you don't get elected we'll give you a
great job as a lobbyist or if you did
get elected when you want to retire you
can have a great job
who's to blame for that
yeah i i tell you it's the law creator
the person that creates the laws it's
not the person that that bribes the law
no you don't have to you don't have to
take the bribe no i did that though in
other countries and i was and i took the
bribe myself so i got to tell you
sometimes you don't feel like you really
got a choice so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]